en este vídeo quiero platicar acerca del
lenguaje que utilizamos cuando
trabajamos en geometría geometría así
que déjame empezar con la palabra
geometría geometría viene del griego geo
que quiere decir tierra tierra y metría
que quiere decir medir medir entonces
etimológicamente geometría quiere decir
medir la tierra pero a lo mejor no es el
mejor nombre que puede tener porque en
geometría hacemos más cosas en geometría
estudiamos todas las formas estudiamos
el espacio y vemos cómo las cosas que se
observan se relacionan entre sí entonces
cuando hablamos de geometría hablamos
por ejemplo de líneas de círculos de
triángulos pero también de otras cosas
más especiales como los cubos figuras de
tres dimensiones o también de patrones
en el plano pero después practicaremos
un poco acerca de cada una de estas
cosas por el momento quiero empezar
desde lo más básico y lo más básico que
tenemos en la geometría son los puntos
entonces aquí voy a poner un punto que
es eso que se hace cuando ponemos el
lápiz en el papel y no hacemos nada más
a eso de ahí le llamamos un punto punto
ahora como no está en matemáticas
podemos ponerle el nombre que nosotros
querramos a las cosas digo ya todo el
mundo le llamo punto a esto pero hay una
razón no le llamaron ornitorrinco porque
sería muy largo decirlo y además esto no
se parece a un ornitorrinco por otro
lado pues esto de aquí sí se parece a un
punto y punto es corto verdad se parece
por ejemplo a un punto ortográfico
entonces es cómodo llamarle punto y la
propiedad fundamental de los puntos es
que tienen simplemente una posición es
decir que si estamos en un punto no
podemos salirnos de ese punto de ninguna
forma o sea nos quedamos atorados ahí no
hay libertad de movimiento vale y así
como hay diferentes posiciones pues
también hay diferentes puntos por
ejemplo pudiéramos tener un punto verde
por acá un punto rojo por acá y un punto
azul por acá un punto azul por acá y
todos esos serían puntos distintos ahora
no siempre tenemos la suerte como
ahorita de tener una pluma que tenga así
millones de colores disponibles entonces
sería una buena idea ver alguna forma de
ponerle nombres a estos
bueno para hacer eso le ponemos
etiquetas a los puntos y usualmente eso
se hace con letras mayúsculas entonces
por ejemplo a este punto le podemos
llamar el punto a al punto verde el
punto b y el punto b a este punto de acá
el punto ce y finalmente al azul le
podemos poner el punto d y entonces si
alguien nos pide en cerrar el punto c
pues tenemos que hacer estudiar
vale entonces ya podemos referirnos a
los puntos pero los puntos son un poco
aburridos porque otra vez no tienen nada
de libertad de movimiento a lo mejor
queremos ir del punto a al punto b y
para hacer eso justamente vamos a
conectar el punto a con el punto b
utilizando todos estos puntos que están
digamos alineados y que están entre
ellos dos bueno esta figura que surge al
conectar dos puntos le llamamos un
segmento segmento
de momento
segmento entonces este estos puntos que
están en amarillo son un segmento y
también estos que están aquí abajo estos
que están aquí abajo forman otro
segmento incluidos aquí hay b y aquí
abajo c y d vale entonces tenemos el
segmento amarillo y el segmento morado
pero otra vez sería una buena idea
encontrar una forma de hablar de estos
segmentos sin necesidad de utilizar
colores y para eso lo que vamos a
utilizar son las orillas de los
segmentos estas orillas tienen un nombre
especial se conoce que se conocen como
los extremos del segmento entonces aquí
aquí lo que diríamos lo que diríamos es
que ahí ven a y b son los extremos son
los extremos mi extremos
del segmento vale también se conocen
como puntos extremos ese sería un nombre
más completo pero también podemos verlo
como extremos porque es un poco más
corto entonces aquí hay veces en los
extremos aquí se ve son los extremos y
para ponerle un nombre al segmento
utilizamos sus puntos extremos
utilizamos las dos letras que conforman
que conforman a los extremos y arriba
dibujamos un segmento ese es una muy
buena forma verdad de acordarnos que es
un segmento bueno entonces éste sería el
segmento ave con un segmento arriba y el
de aquí abajo sería el segmento cede le
voy a poner aquí hice de cd o bien el de
abajo también le podemos llamar el
segmento de s cuando conectamos second
de que da la misma figura que conectar
ve con c entonces los dos son nombres
válidos de manera similar aquí aquí
arriba le pudiese pudimos haber puesto
el segmento b
bueno ya tenemos una forma de ponerle
nombres a los segmentos eso está
padrísimo ahora vamos a platicar un poco
acerca de movimiento aquí ya tenemos más
posibilidades de movimiento podemos
movernos en todo el segmento ave cuando
estábamos en un punto no podíamos hacer
nada bueno pues eso tiene un nombre
especial en el punto cuando tenemos cero
de posibilidades de movimiento decimos
que estamos en cero dimensiones o sea
que el punto es una figura de cero
dimensiones lo voy a poner aquí abajo
cero dimensiones dimensiones cuando
estamos en un segmento decimos que
tenemos una dimensión una dimensión sale
entonces un segmento es una figura de
una dimensión aunque nos podamos mover
hacia la izquierda o hacia la derecha
pues en realidad la izquierda o la
derecha sólo sólo son una a la inversa
de la otra entonces nada más tenemos en
libertad de movimiento en en un sentido
vale por ejemplo no podemos ir hacia
arriba o hacia abajo porque nos
saldríamos nos saldríamos del segmento
entonces pues esto difiere un poquito de
la vida real o sea en la vida real si
esto estuviera hecho de estambre
y cierto ancho y pudiéramos movernos
tantito arriba o tantito abajo sin
salirnos pero matemáticamente los
segmentos no tienen esa posibilidad
simplemente podemos movernos sobre el
segmento ave nada más en estas
direcciones vale bueno a esta distancia
que podemos recorrer en el segmento se
le conoce como la longitud del segmento
y a las longitudes se les denota
utilizando los extremos y no poniendo
nada arriba si tenemos un segmento nos
estamos refiriendo al segmento ave a
todos estos puntos pero si nada más
pusiéramos por ejemplo ave
sabe igual a 5 entonces estamos diciendo
que la longitud o bien la distancia de
ave la longitud del segmento es igual a
55 centímetros o metros ahorita no
importa pudiéramos ponerle unidades pero
aquí este 5 quiere decir que eso es la
longitud vale bueno entonces ya tenemos
esta idea de longitud es talla de
segmento pero a lo mejor queremos
movernos más entonces déjame extender un
poco la idea del segmento pero todavía
en una dimensión una forma de hacer eso
es empezar en a avanzar hacia ce y
continuar es decir podemos hacer algo de
este estilo creo que voy a tapar un poco
lo de dimensiones pero bueno entonces
podemos empezar en nada y gracias y
continuar cuanto indefinidamente
entonces ese indefinidamente lo indicó
con una flechita está este bueno este
esta figura que dibuje sigue y sigue y
sigue indefinidamente vale bueno pues a
esta idea de empezar en un punto avanzar
hacia otro y seguir indefinidamente se
le conoce como rayo
esto de aquí es un rayo y un rayo tiene
un punto especial que es el punto
inicial ya ese punto inicial se le llama
vértice
vértice se usa para otras cosas también
en geometría pero bueno aquí cuando
cuando estamos hablando de rayos el
vértice es el punto inicial del rayo
vale y la forma en la cual denotamos los
rayos es la siguiente ponemos el vértice
inicial pero vértice inicial luego el
vértice al cual vamos aquí sería ce y
arriba ponemos una flecha aquí hay que
tener cuidado en los segmentos podríamos
poner a veo vea y daba lo mismo pero en
los rayos y aquí pusiéramos sea éste
sería un rayo distinto éste empezaría en
se iría aa y se seguiría ahora hacia
allá entonces éste no es un nombre
correcto para lo que dibujamos vale el
nombre correcto sería hace con una
flecha hacia la derecha y también
tenemos la posibilidad de seguirnos
hacia el otro lado pero voy a hacer otro
dibujo para que no quede tan encima do
es decir a lo mejor podemos tener algo
de este estilo aquí voy a poner un punto
aquí otro punto déjame llamarle a este d
a éste y lo que podemos hacer ahora es
unir estos dos y seguir hacia ambos
lados algo algún más o menos de este
estilo china y no quedó el punto e en lo
que dibuje algo de este estilo va
entonces voy a indicar que nos seguimos
hacia ambos lados con una flecha en cada
extremo de esta figura bueno pues a esto
que hacemos cuando conectamos dos puntos
y nos seguimos hacia los dos lados se le
conoce como línea recta línea línea
recta a veces puedes ver que qué le
llaman nada más línea o nada más recta
pero su nombre completo es línea recta
línea recta por separado se utilizan por
comodidad
bueno pues las líneas rectas también
tienen una forma de escribirse tenemos
que poner los dos puntos o algunos dos
puntos que la conformen entonces en este
caso sería d
y arriba ponemos un segmento con dos
flechitas en sus orillas
entonces ya ya platicamos de segmentos
de rayos y de líneas rectas ahora lo más
típico en geometría son los segmentos
porque los segmentos son así como que
muy muy finitos o sea son algo como que
no se va hacia hacia el infinito
entonces es algo que se puede medir que
tiene una medida concreta y pues
usualmente los triángulos pues
necesitamos pedirles sus lados y cosas
por el estilo entonces vamos a platicar
un poco más acerca de los segmentos
imagínate que ahora tenemos tenemos un
punto por aquí voy a usar este color
rojo tenemos un punto x tenemos un punto
y un punto vale y vamos a vamos a trazar
el segmento que los une este de aquí y
pensemos que tenemos otro punto también
en este segmento entonces ahí te vamos a
vamos a poner otro punto z déjame
ponerle un poco más como para acá porque
ahorita vamos a platicar de otra cosa
importante entonces cuando tenemos una
situación de este estilo en la cual
tenemos tres puntos que están en un
mismo segmento o también podemos
pensarlo
misma recta si continuáramos este
segmento se haría una recta pero bueno
cuando tenemos esta situación especial
en la cual los tres están en una misma
línea recta
decimos que x xi y zx6 zetas son co
lineales con lineales esto quiere decir
que están alineados vale que están en la
misma recta y eso es algo especial
porque usualmente dos puntos si están en
una recta pero un tercer punto que caiga
en esa recta pues ya es algo especial
usualmente está fuera de la recta vale
bueno entonces decimos que son co
lineales y si tenemos que x 6 estas son
co lineales pero además además x zeta
déjame ponerlo con otro color además x z
es igual a detalle entonces esto también
es algo especial verdad lo que estamos
diciendo es que la distancia de x a z es
la misma que la de zeta h o sea que se
te está justo a la mitad del segmento
bueno a esta situación especial en la
cual se te está alineado con xy jeff y
tenemos que estar justo a la mitad se le
se le dice o decir o en esa situación
decimos que z es punto medio
punto medio medio y es punto medio del
segmento x x ye y tenemos que ponerle el
segmento vale entonces z es punto medio
del segmento x y eso está interesante
bueno finalmente déjame platicar un poco
más acerca de dimensiones ya vimos
figuras que tienen cero dimensiones
figuras que tienen una dimensión como
sería algo con dos dimensiones bueno
sería algo en donde tenemos dos
posibilidades de movimiento
por ejemplo la pantalla es algo con dos
dimensiones este vídeo aquí en la
pantalla podemos movernos hacia allá
hacia allá pero no sólo así verdad
también podemos movernos hacia allá
hacia allá si no no quiere quedar bonito
hacia allá y hacia allá y con esto es
suficiente para cubrir la pantalla o sea
si nos vemos para acá luego podemos
movernos para acá y podemos llegar a
cualquier punto de la pantalla nada más
con estas dos posibilidades de
movimiento a las figuras que tienen esta
propiedad que podemos recorrer con dos
posibilidades de movimiento les llamamos
figuras planas
planas y hay una especial que consiste
en tomar tomar una hoja de papel una
hoja de papel
y continuarla indefinidamente piensa que
está ahí volando la hoja de papel está
la continuamos indefinidamente bueno a
esta figura que es una hoja de papel
continuar indefinidamente se le conoce
como plano como plano y una hoja de
papel así sin extenderse pues yo creo
que pudiéramos llamarle un segmento de
plano que eso estaba un poco raro verdad
a lo mejor no no no le llaman así en la
escuela pero otra vez estamos en
matemáticas entonces lo que no está
definido lo podemos definir si lo
hacemos con mucho cuidado pero bueno
entonces ya tenemos el plano tenemos
figuras planas y podemos ir más allá ya
lo mejor podemos hablar de figuras en
tres dimensiones y para eso déjame hacer
el siguiente dibujo lo que vamos a hacer
a ver si se entiende es indicar que que
además de la pantalla además de la
pantalla podemos tener movimientos hacia
afuera de la pantalla como hacia ti
imagínatelo hacia ti o hacia adentro de
la pantalla hacia adentro de la pantalla
entonces cuando tenemos una situación de
este de este estilo como el mundo en que
vivimos pues decimos que tenemos una
figura en tres dimensiones y esto ya es
hablar acerca del espacio
del espacio vale bueno entonces tenemos
este cosas de una dimensión cosas planas
cosas en el espacio y después cuando
vayamos aprendiendo matemáticas más
avanzadas veremos que podemos ir todavía
más allá de las tres dimensiones